we are a few days away from 2017 and
there's one thing we all have in common
in 2017 regardless of your age height
education talent doesn't matter we all
have 52 weeks in 2017 just like there's
52 cards in a deck of cards now the one
thing about a deck of cards is very
simple if you look at a deck of cards
you got different colors diamonds clubs
hearts spades and you have two jokers
here in life if you consider numbers
anything between two and eight is a set
back if you look at nine and up it's a
victory but an ace is a massive victory
and Joker let you say this represents
luck you getting lucky which there's
nothing wrong with that
you see if I take this right here and I
shuffle this deck here and I constantly
go through a couple shuffles I don't
know what cards are going to come we're
doing this live nothing about this is
being cut edited anything like that we
have 52 cards and two jokers
sometimes when you're running a business
you're not getting lucky bad things
happen in tears you know my gosh this
was terrible this was too difficult this
was too tough but here's the deal I
don't know what's the next card this
represents first week let's just say
week one this is my first week card what
is it I got a nine decent sale let's
just say this is a second week I got a
five setback cancel next card three
terrible to clients cancelled next week
ten add two big sales next week's two
terrible week next week Jack good week
next week three bad week next week ace a
massive sale a massive victory a massive
opportunity just came my way but because
I went through seven eight cards I got
my ace you know what happens with most
people this is the problem with most
people most people give up right after a
three right after another three or two
they just have this thing's not working
for me
that's wrong the aces are on the corner
for you if if you keep going through it
next card to next card King next card
Queen next card King makes cards open I
just got lucky I just got lucky
see
if you can hang tight for 52 weeks in
2017 and you go hardcore every single
week for the entire year 52 weeks 2017
you're pretty much guaranteed to get
four aces and you're lucky twice if you
do your part right my challenge to you
in 2017 start strong from the beginning
and don't put your head up just keep
your head down and work to the fifty
second week comes I promise you you're
going to have several big victories to
be excited about on December 31st of the
following year of 2017